so this is the new iPad pro it is an
incredible tablet still AM iPad though
[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm poppy HD here
and let me just spoil this whole thing
for you right off the top the new ipad
pro's hardware is actually incredible
like it's the most beautiful most
powerful most impressive ipad yet but
thanks to iOS 12 it's just that it's
just an iPad it's not any closer to
replacing my laptop use it's not any
more likely to be my main computer
but it's easily the best iPad ever okay
let me show you to me so this iPad pro
looks like one of those renders of what
people in the past imagined a tablet
would look like before the iPad existed
is crazy thin it's 5.9 millimeters
completely flat it has an incredible
nearly bezel as display somehow has huge
really impressive speakers and super
powerful solid-state insides so right
off the bat there's an 11 inch or a
12-point nine inch version and there's a
space grey or silver I will say the
smaller one is much more reasonable and
I think it's one most people will get
but I'm a big screen person so here I am
with the crazy big 12 point 9 inch iPad
pro and I prefer Space Gray but that's
up to you
and it's just a marvel to hold like
there are pretty sharp edges all the way
around but I love that it's boxy like
the iPhone 5s was it stands up on its
own
and it's so light the weight
distribution is so even throughout the
whole slab that you can hold it with a
single finger in the middle of the Apple
logo all of this means it's really easy
to hold the edges are kind of sharp like
I said and they can maybe dig into your
hands a bit if you're holding it for a
long time with the heavier iPad but even
that is rare battery I thought would
suffer from being so thin nope this
tablet has a plus battery life again and
the speakers on either side they have
precision milled holes that I just think
look really good and yet again the
drivers are loud they're far enough
apart for stereo effect they just
somehow keep getting better the camera
on the back is the same as the iPhone 10
s and 10 are and the bump is pretty big
because the iPad is so thin but it's way
over in the corner so my hands never
really accidentally touch it or anything
and the tablet is so big and so flat
that it actually doesn't really affect
the whole lying down flat on a table
thing it still doesn't rock back and
forth I guess if I had to pick something
that I don't like about the design it
would be actually the extra and 10
on the cellular version which I picked
they're just not symmetrical they don't
look very even just just a little little
off looking little extra the Wi-Fi
version has antenna lines too but
there's not as many but I'm never
looking at the back of the iPad anyway
so it doesn't really bother me oh and no
headphone jack of course but you already
know how I feel about that this is Apple
we're talking about here and I'm kind of
already on that wireless life anyway
anyway I have like little little hopes
now of a new iPhone next year kind of
looking like this like being really
squared off and boxy but then pushing
the display to the edge yeah I don't
know it probably won't happen if they
want to keep wireless charging of course
but I still would love that so clearly I
like the outside the aesthetics the feel
in the hand is awesome hardware and on
the inside it gets even more impressive
first of all there's no finger Parader
no home button since the bezels are so
thin but there is the whole suite of
face ID sensors in the iPad pro and they
work now in any orientation so you can
be portrait landscape upside down no
matter what it works which is helpful
because the fact that the front of the
iPad is so uniform makes it easy to
forget which way is the top sometimes
you grab it and you try to unlock it in
your hand is covering the sensor since
the bezels so thin but it just points a
little arrow and tells you you're
covering the sensor so you can unblock
it and then you're in and the display is
again easily not just one of the best in
any tablet but one of the best screens
I've ever used
it's the 120 Hertz IPS LCD super
accurate colors great viewing angles
ultra responsive and smooth and very
bright when you need it true tone there
also if you want it and the
anti-reflective coating is great so face
ID is good
the display is about as good as it gets
and then the specs now you've probably
heard me say before about Apple products
the numbers don't really matter as much
and that's still true here but let me
give you this a 12 X Bionic is
absolutely incredible it is the fastest
chip I've ever seen in a mobile device
if you've seen Geekbench scores that's
been pretty popular lately as
benchmarking faster than many laptops
rivaling the 15-inch MacBook Pro it has
four gigs of RAM and for some reason the
one terabyte iPad has six gigs of RAM
but generally performance is just really
good from multitasking the flying
through apps
productivity photo-editing it's all fast
and fluid it's a plus performance just
like the previous iPad pro but now you
have Headroom for days like it's more
about being future-proof and you're very
future proof here and then even the
accessory ecosystem is all upgraded the
new Apple pencil way better obviously
you can't get much more awkward than
this was it's not a high bar to clear
but it is now great it snaps on to the
side of the iPad with magnets and pears
and wirelessly charges there there's a
little cutout on the side of this
all-metal iPad that lets the wireless
charging work through here and it lines
everything up I just think I missed out
on an opportunity to call the
second-generation Apple pencil a number
two pencil maybe maybe that's just me
anyway there's also now a new thinner
folio case and a new keyboard case as
well these aren't things I use very much
I do sometimes have the folio on and
they now connect via magnets throughout
the whole back of the iPad and they line
up really quickly and snap into place
which makes them easy to put on and take
off but sturdy while it is connected so
here's the fun visual I show this on
Twitter this is what you could call
magnet paper something like that it has
filaments inside that respond to a
magnetic charge and when you pass it
over something like the iPad it can show
you where inside the magnets are so you
put it down on the iPad and you can see
that there are magnets a lot of them
everywhere all around the perimeter and
they match up with the same magnet in
Apple's accessories and that's what
helps them lock into place so quickly
and easily that pins always line up it's
smart and I'll leave a link below if you
want to get some of this magic paper to
look and see where magnets are at other
things the most Apple and 2018 thing
ever though is all the price hikes so
every single thing we just talked about
the new pencil the new folio case the
keyboard case and a tablet itself are
all more expensive than last year's
versions which again you can't ignore
that but you could also argue these all
works so well together better than any
third-party version that that's why
people including myself keep buying
these so what's the holdup iOS 12 and
it's weird to say because iOS 12 is
great it's the best version of iOS yet
by a lot and it's my favorite but on
this hardware it leaves a lot to be
desired like don't get me wrong it's an
incredible iPad
but every year when you know the new
iPad pro comes out we revisit this
conversation of chemists replace my
laptop can it be my primary computer you
know it's it's a better performer now
it's benchmarking higher than my old
laptop it's got more storage than a
laptop it has a better display it's a
touchscreen it's 120 Hertz it's more
expensive surely this can replace my
laptop right well I wish I could replace
my computer with an iPad pro because I
enjoy using the iPad that much more but
there are still things that I need to do
on a pretty regular basis that the iPad
doesn't that I need to keep a laptop
around for the big ones no file
ecosystem so if I'm photo editing and I
want to bring other files in it's kind
of incredibly annoying like this thing
needs finder not the current files app
I'm a youtuber I want to be able to go
to the YouTube for desktop site and then
go into the YouTube studio and go
through analytics and studio features
that way mobile safari will not let me
it kicks me out into the YouTube app
every single time staying with Google
Drive there is a Google Drive app but I
want the desktop app with all the
desktop features and the desktop UI and
I can't do that in the default browser
there's no trackpad or Mouse support in
iOS at all so the keyboard works great
if you have one but you can plug in any
Mouse in the world and it won't do
anything
and then the USB C port you'd think
would unlock a world of possibilities of
connecting all kinds of accessories and
being able to talk to them through the
iPad first of all Thunderbolt
accessories don't work at all like they
would on a laptop only USB type-c does
so you can plug in a display for example
but this is something you could already
do with lightning and still all it will
do is mirror the display but now it's up
to 5k so the closest I can get to my
ideal scenario at least with creative
stuff on the iPad pro is photo editing
actually so my camera of choice is a
Hasselblad x1d it has a USB type-c port
so when I plug it in to the iPad pro
nothing happens it actually it just
starts charging the camera so while
that's a letdown I basically will have
to take the SD card out and I have a USB
see two SD card adapter I plug that in
then I get to import the file it goes
into photos I can bring that into
Lightroom and then I can do all my edits
with the raw file and editing on the
iPad pro is easily my favorite way of
editing photos with the pencil with the
awesome hundred twenty
display it's great but that's exactly
what I could do with the Lightning port
before in fact there's virtually nothing
really new that I can do with the USBC
port on the iPad pro that I couldn't
already do with a lightning adapter all
I'm doing is getting rid of the dongles
and I love that I don't need a $40.00
Lightning dongle anymore but thanks to
iOS it doesn't mean as much now as I
think it could in the future so
basically this iPad pro the hardware
like I've said it's crazy it's great
it's better than a lot of laptops it's
better than Apple's cheapest laptops
actually but it's definitely still an
iPad it does all the same things that
the previous iPad pro did just better
and that is like a textbook like great
thing to say about a product it's it's
all better than what it did last year
but like this conversation of or at
least what Apple tries to do of
comparing it to laptops over and over
again puts it in a weird space and I've
seen people who's who's creative
workflows happen to fit this iPad pro
into the puzzle of what they do
perfectly I'm so jealous of those people
there's people who will sketch for hours
on the iPad pro who are DJs on the iPad
Pro who are doing video editing on the
iPad Pro and if it does meet your needs
for that then this is an incredible an
incredible iPad this all has me thinking
about two things one maybe iOS 13 when
that comes out will really turn the iPad
into it's its true form its final form
it'll unlock the USB C port to do way
more things
it'll have better file management it'll
do all these things to get it closer to
a main computer maybe and to when is
Apple gonna start putting their
incredibly powerful chips in Macs like
in the new MacBook Air which is running
and slightly underpowered Intel chip
maybe that's coming in the future
sometime soon
maybe but until then this is just the
greatest iPad ever thanks for watching
talk to you the next one peace